in our series our world with mothers we
look at what motherhood means in
different countries around the globe
this morning we're going to Finland
which is consistently ranked one of the
best places to be a mom the country's
praised for its low infant and mother
mortality rates paid maternity leave and
health care and daycare systems as Holly
Williams found out the government of
Finland even gives new moms a big old
gift she joins us from Istanbul Turkey
where she's based Holly good morning to
you good morning as you can probably see
I am pregnant
my baby is due later on this month so
I'm no longer doing any travel for work
but a few weeks ago I went to Finland to
see what exactly they're getting right
when it comes to motherhood and how
they're doing it a woman in labor has
gone into cardiac arrest these medics
need to save her life and her baby but
this patient is just a mannequin and
here at Helsinki University Hospital
they hold emergency drills like this one
once a week Finland's health care system
has helped give it the lowest maternal
death rate in the world and it's
available here to everyone for next to
nothing
dr. identic i is the chief physician on
the labor board every mother here gets a
private room and even the option of a
water birth 100 euros you will pay and
you will of that you will get almost 50%
back is any reimbursement that's under
$60 to have a baby compared with the US
where the average natural birth costs
over $12,000 and insurance doesn't cover
all of it can what Finland is doing be
replicated in a country like the u.s.
definitely you're saying there's no
reason that the US can't achieve this no
no reason but this purely politic I
think politics here the maternal death
rate in the US has nearly doubled over
the last three decades in Finland
they've cut it in half at a playgroup in
Helsinki we
met Laura Smith from Detroit who's
living here with her finish husband and
their 10 month old baby Ella maternal
death rates are even higher for
african-american women one of the
reasons Laura chose to have Ella in
Finland instead of back home my concerns
mattered my voice mattered they saw me
they they took care of me no matter what
I look like and that's something I
couldn't be certain about in the state
so when you come back mother and baby
are also entitled to free checkups so
these are vaccinations yeah and when
Ella goes to daycare that'll cost less
than $100 a week it's all paid for with
tax dollars the wealthy hand over much
more in Finland than the u.s. we are
collecting a lot of taxes but if you go
and ask from the Finns are they okay
with that everybody is saying yes we
have get used with that system the
system began in the 1930s when Finland
started handing out free baby boxes to
new families filled with basic
necessities they're still giving them
out today the Box doubles as a makeshift
cot and the government also wants
parents to spend time with their babies
in Finland you're guaranteed around four
months paid maternity leave by law and
parents can then split another six
months paid parental leave though not at
the same time for Elenita and julienne
that's more time spent with their three
daughters in some parts of the US you
get no paid maternity leave well how do
you do then
the long frozen winter in Finland is
hard but this is one country where
they're trying to make Parenthood easier
nobody who we met in Finland bragged
about their success rather they're
trying try to figure out how to improve
things even further for instance by
encouraging more fathers to take
paternity leave and that government
minister who you just saw is trying to
figure out how to encourage Finn's to
have more babies because despite all of
those benefits the birth rate in Finland
is declining Gail that's an interesting
little nugget thank you very much Holly
Williams reporting from Istanbul
tomorrow on CBS this morning we continue
our world of mothers series in Kenya
we'll take you to a tiny village in
northern Kenya where young women have
escaped domestic violence and are
learning to become mothers in an area
where men are banned I like how they're
thinking in Finland though don't you
yeah you know when I was there last
summer our tour guide told us that women
and my families could just drop their
kids off in a local park and they have
paid nannies there that take care of the
kids during when the parents go to work
so just well society needs to decide how
they're gonna pay for it there's a 24
percent sales tax even though I'm just
sort of reading that the minimum tax
rate individual tax rate is about 25
percent and so if Americans decide they
want to pay more and they trust their
government to do that these are the
outcomes there you can hum well and they
made a different choice made a different
choice and some would say that's they've
made the choice to have 50 million
people be uninsured and that that's
they've decided that's that's okay so
it's certainly something else in a much
smaller country that's why we do these
doors yeah exactly they give you a
course you say children are valuable
they are